- I have someone that's better
than Belichick.
- Yeah, OK.
- I honestly was gonna,
as I call it, "Troy Polamalu."
- Oh, you were gonna
jump over the line?
- I was gonna jump over the line.
♪♪♪
- What up? Welcome to another
episode of "Simms & Lefkoe."
But guess what?
- Whoa!
It's not just you and me and
your weird "Star Trek" shirt.
We've got ourselves
an awesome guest.
I'm just kidding, Woody.
The shirt's awesome.
Jamal Adams.
Best safety in the NFL.
- Yes.
- El Presidente.
How you feelin', man?
- I'm feelin' good, man, feelin' good.
- Do you agree with me
that you're the best
safety in the NFL?
- I do. I do.
- Where is your level right now?
You look around the league,
how confident are you
and why is it clicking so well?
- I'm just getting started, man.
I'm just, you know, scraping
the surface, as I call it.
But, you know, I just wanna
continue to get better
each and every day.
I'm working on
the little things.
I'm just trying to be the best
at those things.
Obviously
my interception numbers
are not high as others—
- Oh, no.
You stink, then.
- But that's where, you know—
- Statistics are bulls--t.
- The world is kinda going
as far as who's the best,
but at the end of the day
man, I know what
I'm capable of doing.
- Yeah.
- I know what I can bring
to the field
and bring to the team.
- You guys share the connection.
Your pops.
- We do got a little connection.
His dad, George Adams,
like, one of the guy—
had a bad hip injury
that really ruined his career.
But I know, just from
my dad's perspective
it was always George Adams.
Your father always comes up as
one of those guys of, "What if?"
- Right.
- Cuz I know he thinks he's one—
- And they played together.
- They played together, yeah.
I mean, he was on
the '86 Super Bowl team.
- So you're telling me
that your dad, his dad
and Mark Ingram's dad were
all on the same team together?
- Isn't that crazy?
Yeah, yeah.
- That's crazy.
- Whaaat?
- I know.
- And now here's
this generation.
- Right.
Me, the scrub
and then these two guys
made something of their lives.
- You talk about humility.
I am sensing a trend that
is the opposite of that.
Every interception,
every fumble recovery
I'm watching defenses
run into the end zone—
- Yeah.
- And they're all sittin' there,
and they're posin'
the big lineman get in the back,
and they're like this.
Every game I see it now.
- Right. Yeah. It's gettin' old.
- What do you think of the trend?
- I hate it.
- Really?
- Yeah.
Because—and it's
crazy you said that.
I really do hate it.
Because, one thing,
it's the Saints' thing.
Let the Saints do it.
The Saints were the first—
- So you're giving it
to the Saints?
- I think, from what I've seen
and what I, what I know
I think the Saints
were the first people to do it.
- Are you tired of the Saints
doing it?
Or everybody?
- No, absolutely not. It's them.
- So they can do it?
- Yeah, they can do it.
- It's theirs.
- It's theirs. Let them have their thing.
- Interesting. Cuz I was at the Bills game
last year
where you guys were dancing
in the commercial.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And I thought that was gonna
be the same thing.
So you think that celebration
is a Saints thing.
Everybody else should stop.
- Yeah, I believe so.
- OK.
- Because it's crazy.
Mo Claiborne
got a pick versus the Colts.
- Yeah.
- He ran it back
and guys ran over there
and tried to do the—
They did it.
I kinda like, ran and—
- You didn't do it?
- I didn't do it.
I ran off.
- Wow.
- And my coach laughed at me
and he made a joke and said
"Oh, you're an individual,"
but—
He was messing with me,
but at the same time
man, I just didn't—
I enjoyed it.
- Yeah.
- I enjoyed that my brother made
a pick and he made a pick-six.
- It's gotta be fun.
- But I just couldn't—
I couldn't get into that
celebration
because it's not mine.
- That's interesting.
- It's not my team's.
- I like this guy.
- Yeah!
- No copyright infringement
for his celebration.
- Nah.
- Yeah, he's not a poser at all.
You faced Tom Brady three times.
- Yeah.
- What is it about him—
do you have a play
or an example
that shows how much
he owns that position?
- Honestly, there was a play
this last game.
I tried to jump the snap.
I honestly was gonna,
as I call it, "Troy Polamalu."
- Oh, you were gonna
jump over the line.
- I was gonna jump over the line.
I definitely was.
- Good for you.
- Obviously I knew the play.
I knew it was a run play.
And I was honestly tryin'
to get him.
But he looked at me,
and I kinda looked away
and then I looked—
- You were like,
"Don't make eye contact!"
- Yeah, I'm like,
"Don't make eye contact."
Then I looked at him,
and I looked at the clock.
It was like 8.
Then I'm like, "OK..."
Usually around the,
around 6 or 7
he's been snapping the ball
this whole game.
- OK.
- As soon as 6 hit, I take off.
He sees me.
He holds it.
And then get they get me.
He was gonna, he was
gonna double-count me.
- Cuz he saw that
you were gonna jump.
- But he saw that I—
he knew I was coming.
- Right.
He just does
the little things consistently.
And he takes advantage
of your mistakes.
He waits for you to make
a mistake because
he's not gonna make a mistake,
more than likely.
- Yeah.
- Just waiting for you to be there.
- He's just waiting.
He's just waiting.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah. Respect to him.
- You're great.
- You are great.
- But I'm looking at your shirt.
This is something you worked on
with Bleacher Report.
Missing in football
right now is tackling.
And we think that you have
a lot of pent-up anger
and we wanna
take care of that.
And we have a special
place in mind.
- Let's do it.
♪♪♪
- For all of my haters...
- [Laughing]
That's incredible.
The ceiling came down.
- We're tired of
your constant winning
and your sustained excellence
and you get all the calls,
and we're just done with it!
I hate you so much!
- [Laughing]
- For those who said
I couldn't cover Gronk.
Damn.
- Holy crap.
- Wow.
- I felt like a lot of that
came out of you there.
- Yeah, a lot
of frustration, man.
Uh...damn it.
- Look at that.
- Yeah, he's gotta go
to the blue tent now.
- I'm sick of being accessible
all the time!
I'm sick of walkin' around
New York City
with everybody like this
and they don't even look
at anybody anymore.
- Bum-ba-duh-duh!
- New phone, who dis?
- This is to every person
in the Instagram comment section
with a big f--king mouth.
- [Laughing]
God, that feels so good.
- It does.
I get it.
Damn, that was a good one.
- They're doin' an hour-long
Phil Simms special.
What do you think about it?
- Oh, but we need to fix this TV.
I like it.
- [Laughing]
- Aaaah!
- That relieve any of the stress?
- Most definitely, man.
Felt damn good.
- See?
That's why people come on
"Simms & Lefkoe."
We're the Players' Show.
- It's true, it's true.
- We are here for you.
We're the Players' Show.
- It's true, it's true.
- We are here for you.
- [Smashing glass]
Ahh! Damn you!
- Tell you what, receivers
are in trouble
cuz now he's loosened up
and ready to go.
- Over with.
- Smashing stuff
with Jamal Adams.
Bucket list.
He was strong.
Like, very strong.
Like, the first time
he threw the printer
the tile fell out
of the ceiling.
- Yeah, he's awesome.
He's the best safety
in football.
And that was a lot of fun.
I'll say this.
That damn Patriots shot glass?
I threw that against the wall,
and it didn't break.
- You looked at it like it was
like, had a haunted
spirit in it.
- I feel like Bill Belichick
built the damn thing
or somethin'.
I was like
"Oh, it's indestructible
like the Patriots."
- Yeah, Jamal's gonna be
in trouble now.
Now that he's threatened
the great Bill Belichick.
They might have a new coach
for the Jets.
They're definitely gonna have
a new coach for the Packers.
And as the gambling guy—
- Hello, gambling guy.
- I have some odds here
that I'm very curious—I wanna
get your football mind on.
- We're not gonna talk about
the Pete Carmichaels
or the Eric Bieniemys.
We're gonna start off first,
the gambling favorite—
- Right.
- 2-1
John DeFilippo, current
OC of the Vikings.
Should he be the favorite
in your mind?
- No. He should not be.
I do think that John DeFilippo
is a guy that has
head coach in his future.
It's his second year
really being an offensive
coordinator at the NFL level.
And I would also
argue this, Lefkoe.
His base offense is very similar
to Mike McCarthy.
It's West Coast-based.
I think they need
some different ideas
some different ideology
in that building.
- I got a guy for you.
- Oh, you got a guy?
- It's the No. 2.
- You got a guy.
- Plus-225.
- Ooh.
- Josh McDaniels.
- Yes.
- OC of the Patriots.
My first question is,
after the Colts hired him
and then he walked away
do you think the Packers
would take that risk?
- I will say this.
As much respect I have
for the Colts and all that
I do think this is
a little different job.
I mean, last year the Colts
certainly are not
the Green Bay Packers
as far as historic franchises.
Andrew Luck and the shoulder
issue was a big question mark.
- He hadn't played in a year,
so I can see that question mark.
- Exactly right. Right.
So now you're going Green Bay.
It's Titletown.
It's Vince Lombardi.
It's frozen tundra.
- Lambeau Field.
- Right.
It's one of the original teams
in the NFL.
And you feel like,
"Oh, I can go there
and get off
to a pretty good start."
They got Aaron Rodgers
at quarterback.
- Yeah.
- And so you're gonna feel good
about that.
It's probably the one
I'd like to see the most.
- All right. We like offense
for Aaron Rodgers.
We're goin' to college
for this big-time offense.
Oklahoma, Lincoln
Riley at 10-1.
- Right.
- Does this make sense to you?
Could this be the offense
that Aaron needs
to put up 40 points a game?
- No, I don't really understand
how this became a hot topic.
I really don't.
I understand, he's a
really good coach.
I've been around him.
- You like his schematics.
- I like his schematics
for college football.
- Oh.
- For the NFL level, people
would look at that and go
"What's so special?"
He's playin' in the Big 12
where they play
two or three defenses
the whole game, the whole year.
There's not a lot of good
defensive players in general.
I just think that it's
a little too early for me
to say Lincoln Riley to the NFL.
- So, I have someone that's
better than Belichick.
- Yeah, OK.
- I've looked at this list,
and I'm unimpressed.
- I always know when your, like
your mind's going
into Creativeville here.
- I have someone
that isn't just offense.
- Oh.
- They're not just defense.
- They're not just special teams.
They're one with everything.
- Who you goin'?
- I have somebody that
is world-renowned.
- Right.
- Tony Dungy type of vibe.
- Wow.
I'd like to introduce you
to the next head coach
of the Green Bay Packers
the Dalai Lama, His Holiness.
- How's his clock management?
- Look at Aaron's smile.
Have you seen Aaron smile
like that in the last year?
- Well, no. I think he's smiling
cuz he's going
"Man, this guy's gonna
be my new head coach
and he doesn't even know
what this thing he's holding is.
He doesn't even know
how to hold it."
- But maybe that's what
they need in Green Bay.
- Oh.
- Maybe they've been doing
the same thing for so long,
they need someone
that doesn't know the thing
that they've done for so long.
- I'm sure
the Dalai Lama has—
- Fast-forward three years.
- Right.
- Two playoff losses and a little,
you know, 7-9 season.
- Oh, he put on some weight.
- He put on some weight.
- That stress, this job.
- He's goin'
"Hey, 'Wisconsin Post Gazette,'
I've answered you already.
We practice outdoors."
He's turning into Patricia.
- Oh, I was gonna say, OK.
- The Packers coaching job.
It's really tough.
-It is tough.
-What do you think?
-I don't think so, sorry.
Great guy.
I mean, awesome.
I wanna meet him one day.
- "Great guy"?
- Yeah, yeah.
That's what they tell me.
- Good guy.
- That's what they tell me.
- Who's "they"?
- I don't know.
I just read it in the paper,
the news.
- What's up? I'm Tarik Cohen
running back for
Chicago Bears
and you're watching
"Simms & Lefkoe."
Oy vey!
- Only a few "Thursday Night
Football" games left
and, honestly,
I'm tired of trying.
I found Allie.
He's really good.
He's 5-2.
He got the Saints wrong.
But I'm feeling better
about this week.
I hope Allie is.
Allie!
- Hey!
- Are you surprised to see me?
- Yeah, man.
I am, I am.
- Let it out.
- You know what, man?
I felt a little bad.
- I've never done this before.
I've never come back
to somebody that's lost.
- Yes, I know.
I know. And you know what?
I'm happy you're back.
- OK.
- I think that Dallas did what
they were supposed to do.
- Yeah.
- They got at Drew Brees
shook him up a little bit
and made it difficult.
- Simms told me to give you
a message.
"Screw you.
I'm the Oracle."
I believe that's what he told me
to tell you.
- I'mma have to swallow
that this week.
- Yeah.
- [Laughing]
As punishment though—
- OK.
- I'm giving you
Titans-Jaguars.
We went from that incredible
Thursday night game to this one
where it's just trying
not to be in last place.
Titans are favored by 4.5.
- OK.
- Break it down.
Who you goin' with?
- Titans are favored
by 4.5 at home.
- At home.
Titans have historically had
the Jaguars' number.
Jaguars' new quarterback
scored six points and got a win.
Titans came back
and beat the Jets.
- I still think
that the Titans...
4.5?
- Yes.
- Will pull it off at home.
- I agree with you, at home.
- This is one of
those toss-up games.
It's, like, 50-50.
- They're still fightin'
for the playoffs.
- Yeah.
- OK.
- Titans.
- Sure?
- Yes.
Lock it in.
- All right. You're 5-2.
When I come back next week,
I want you to be 6-2.
- 6-2.
- I don't know about 5-3.
- Nope. I hope they win.
- Holy crap.
What do you know, Simms?
Allie went with the favorite.
- Yeah.
- We've been tracking, he has
a tendency to pick favorites.
But he's my guy.
He did say that you're
still the Oracle for this week.
- I really like you, man.
I'm gonna come visit you
at some point and say hi.
But I just want to give you
a hard time every time
we have a show.
Every other NFL show
I hear about still talks
about the Chiefs, and they still
talk about the Chargers
and we just wanna be
honest with you guys.
It's probably gonna go through
New England.
When we look
at the Chiefs and we look
at the Chargers and we look
at the Steelers and the Texans
and all these teams
in the playoffs
the Ravens right now.
- Yeah.
- Of all those teams
who has the best chance
of going into New England
and beating the Patriots?
- I'm going with your team that
you picked for the Super Bowl.
The Houston Texans.
- Wow.
Nine-in-a-row Texans.
- Yeah.
I think that makes sense.
- Wait, who picked them?
- You did.
- Oh, wow.
- No, please continue.
- Now, you picked them
playing Green Bay, but...
- Yeah, don't talk about that.
- So we'll avoid that.
- Don't talk about that.
- But either way,
the Houston Texans
I do look at it,
for two reasons.
One, we have seen coaches
with familiarity
give Bill Belichick
and Josh McDaniels problems.
- Except for Bill O'Brien,
but yes.
- Right. But, OK, and then,
the other thing I like about them—
We've seen the formula
to beat the New England Patriots
and Tom Brady, right?
The two Super Bowl losses.
The AFC championship losses.
- You're right, the Giants
and the Eagles.
- Right. The Broncos and the Ravens,
who gave them a hard time.
They can get there
with four guys, right?
I think the Texans are a team
to watch out for
with their ability
to run and that QB.
- You know what else is
a great way to beat New England?
- Yeah?
- A quarterback that Belichick
can't game-plan for.
- Sure, right.
- And Deshaun Watson's that guy.
- He is.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- What a pick by me.
- I got a man-crush
on the Texans.
You know, they play—
- I thought he was gonna say me.
- No. Definitely not on you.
Sorry.
- That's unfortunate.
- For Simms—
- Peace out, homies.
- I am the L-E-F-K-O-E.
- Man.
- And we're leaning forward
because we want you
to know how much we care.
Have a great day.
Enjoy the games.
Peace.
- Pew-pew-pew-pew-pew
- AND1 mixtape.
♪♪♪
"Simms & Lefkoe."
The Players' Show.
Makin' you feel better, man.
- That's what I'm talkin'
'bout, man.
- Sorry, I didn't tell you
I was gonna—
- Damn.
- Oh s--t.
- I got excited!
- Was that supposed to happen?
- He dead!
- I think you're good.